morgen ist es endlich soweit das große
jubiläum 30 jahre deutsche einheit
und ich höre direkte üblichen
korinthenkacker das war gar keine
wiedervereinigung das war bloß ein
beitritt nach artikel 23
quasi ein anschluss der neuen brd
kolonie deutsch nordost ihr werdet mir
die feiern nicht vermiesen blöden oergel
fritzen 30 jahre deutsche einheit das
schreit doch nach einem epo hall
besorgnis bitte fällt aus wegen corona
man kann spaß haben mit weniger alkohol
beispielsweise das geht doch auch geht
nicht wieder
andererseits vielleicht auch ganz gut
dass der übliche festakt zum dritten
oktober diesmal anders läuft rechte an
die letzten bühnenprogrammen zum dritten
oktober denke diese ganze kunst scheiße
du hier wurde zb in einem ausdruckstanz
die steiß geburt deutsche einheit
nachgestellt türen waren verschlossen
damit keine abhaut und das hier ja das
strich glaube ich für sich selbst
[Musik]
wo ist der küken schredder wenn man ihn
braucht 30 jahre ein jubiläum auf dass
wir tatsächlich stolz sein können müssen
ja auch wenn es nur ein beitritt war
sofort was halten beitritt wenn du was
wir seitdem alles gemeinsam geschafft
haben also vor allem ich aber ist ja
egal klar
im nachhinein wenn man die zeit gehabt
hätte vielleicht hätte man auch eine
gemeinsame verfassung erarbeiten können
mehr augenhöhe hält sicher oder weil sie
nicht wenigstens als symbolische geste
so eine gemeinsame hülle die kann man ja
super zusammen manchen die beiden hymnen
hier zweite strophe
recht und freiheit hier gast und schon
die zuvor im bezirk des deutsch schlecht
viel schöner endlich wächst zusammen was
zusammen gehört übrigens sagen umfragen
für menschen um die 30 und jünger ist
das ganze ossi wessi ding längst kein
thema mehr
ja nur noch geschichte oper erzählt vom
krieg natürlich gibt es noch was zu tun
wenn sich 57 prozent der ostdeutschen
immer noch als bürger zweiter klasse
fühlen und sich nach wie vor kein dax
konzern in die neuen länder führt
trotzdem ist es doch viel viel besser
als noch vor ein paar jahren da hieß es
nämlich wenn du einen westdeutschen
triffst und es ist nicht ein verwandter
dann ist es entweder dein vorgesetzter
denn vermieter oder du stehst vor
gericht ja das gilt sogar für das
jüngste gericht gottes nämlich auch was
ich wissen viele gar nicht schluss mit
den alten klischees und konzentration
auf die erfolgsgeschichten nur noch an
die erfolgsgeschichten denken meine
deutschlands große neue boom region
liegen allesamt im osten leipzig rostock
es gibt erfolgreiche und
strukturschwache regionen in ost und
west ehrlich wozu hat die gruppe
überhaupt noch diesen komischen
ostbeauftragten wobei neulich hat
hermann im bundestag was gesagt da habe
ich also wenn sie mich vor schreck fast
an meinem homer sandwich verschluckt
beim verfügbaren einkommen der privaten
haushalte beispielsweise haben meine
heimat bundesland sachsen und
brandenburg zum saarland aufgeschlossen
hat ja die haben zum saarland
aufgeschlossen das saarland ist so am
boden man spricht schon von der sahel
zone
den niedrigsten anteil an prekär
beschäftigten hat heute brandenburg den
höchsten bremen will sagen die gräben in
unserer gesellschaft laufen längst nicht
mehr entlang der alten zonengrenze
sondern zwischen arm und reich stadt und
land aber vor allem auch zwischen jung
und alt ich sage weg vom ganzen ossi
wessi quatsch was sie alle zum
einheitsjubiläum dringend brauchen ist
ein neues gesamtdeutsches feindbild ja
meine wer ist dann schuld am reformstau
im land in der ganzen predigen weiter so
politik werden
die 60er jahre geburtsstunde einer
schlimmen spezies babyboomer keine
generation hat so viel schaden
angerichtet
sie zerstören die natur das klima die
rentenkasse warum sind sie so viele weil
in den 60er jahren ständig ohne pille
gefegt wurde
vielen dank auch roma blockieren mit
ihren branchen alle wichtigen posten
ländern leute wie herrn dollar gause
karl lauterbach veronica ferres spiel
baxter heiko maas und leider auch solche
gestalten ihr baby boomer diesen fehler
darf deutschland nie wieder machen
furchtbare menschen frage warum stellt
dieser ostbeauftragte immer noch einmal
im jahr seinen bericht zum stand der
deutschen einheit vor
also wieso ein zeugnis für die menschen
aus den neuen ländern nach dem motto so
dann wollen wir mal gucken wie gut ihr
euch seit letztem jahr integriert haben
vorschlag das wäre das mindeste ab
sofort wird jedes jahr eine andere
deutsche region so bewertet und den
anfang macht baden württemberg genau wir
schauen mal live zur pressekonferenz des
neuen südwest beauftragten kill reiners
den erst jetzt anfangen vielen dank
meine damen und herren baden württemberg
bleibt auch in diesem jahr eine
problemregion mit drei baustellen
wirtschaft mentalität sprache wobei wir
nie vergessen dürfen dieses neue
bundesland im westen gibt es erst seit
damals wurden baden und württemberg
vereinigt für viele immer noch ein
anhaltendes trauma
sie wissen doch sicher auch noch wo sie
waren als ryder tricks genannt wurde der
schwabe ist grundsätzlich in der krise
deswegen spricht der rest der republik
ja auch gerne vom jammer schwaben
entschuldigung oliver welke zdf lügen
presse ich bin jetzt gerade etwas
irritiert sie sprechen dauert nur vom
schwaben ja der bade ist für mich auch
ein schwabe
also können sie das auseinanderhalten
ich nicht also ganz ehrlich können sie
sachsen und thüringer auseinanderhalten
eben kommen wir zum problem bereich
wirtschaft da setzt der schwabe trotz
sich weiter auf verbrennungsmotoren und
müsli eine folge jahrzehntelanger
marktwirtschaftlicher misswirtschaft
trotzdem schaffte es nicht sich
einkommens technisch am bundesschnitt zu
orientieren
zusammen mit hamburg und bayern ist
baden württemberg das reichste
bundesland und bleibt so der ewige
streber mit dem keiner spielen will
da hilft auch keine überbetonung wie
locker man angeblich drauf ist doch die
schwachen sie haben
[Musik]
gebt dem schwaben ein schalldichter soll
ihren keller eine lauwarme flasche
mineralwasser und schon eskaliert die
partie diese zwei singenden büroklammern
zeigen warum das schwabenland weiterhin
in sachen stimmung unser schlusslicht
markiert
kommen wir nun zur sprache hier muss man
quasi von einem endlosen unfall sprechen
und natürlich mögen jetzt die schwarzen
geboren keinen grünen vegetarier aber
war mitmachen bietet halt nur mails
leute gleich an zukäufen euch übrigens
wenn sie das rückwärts abspielen verrät
ihnen der teufel die kommenden
lottozahlen
wir sehen der schwabe lebt in einer
sprachlichen parallelgesellschaft auch
bei der einstellung zur demokratie
auffällig viele schwaben waren auf den
sogenannten querdenker demos in berlin
da bildete sich eine richtige globuli
päda sie nennen sich pietisten ohne
nasenschutz gehen demonstrieren ohne
argumente kurz condor ja was würden sie
sagen ja das warum sind diese querdenker
schwaben so extrem schwer zu integrieren
für viele ist die doppelbelastung
schlicht zu gross kehrwoche und mund
nasen schutz tragen wenn der schwabe die
wahl zwischen sauber im treppenhaus und
andere menschen vor einem virus schützen
sagte er
dann nämlich das treppenhaus denn die
anderen kenne ich gar nicht um ein
treppenhaus kenne ich schon seit 40
jahren fazit es ist noch viel zu tun auf
den weg vom baden württemberger zum
richtigen deutschen so viel von mir und
nächstes jahr ist das saarland unser
sorgenkind themenschwerpunkt dann
strukturwandel weg von der cousine in
zur partnerwahl außerhalb der familie
ich freue mich schon till reiners
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da